in good shape your health magazine on DW
featuring an interview with a different
expert every week
stress in the city it's a big topic and
with me in the studio today is dr. Mazda
oddly he lives in a big city
he lives in Berlin and he's also
carrying out research on this topic
welcome to in good shape hi
so are you doing research on stress in
the city why is that important well the
global population living in cities is
growing dramatically today every 50% of
mankind is living in urban environments
by 2050 about two-thirds of mankind will
be living in cities so urbanization is
the global change that is occurring on
this planet with a lot of health impact
and we're trying to understand what
urbanization does to our psychological
well-being so it's a major health risk
and what is it that makes life in the
cities so stressful well we do see
stress-related diseases in cities such
as depression which occurs more
frequently in in cities such as
schizophrenia twice as frequent in
cities then in rural environments if it
even comes with a dose response
relationship the greater the city you're
going up in the the larger your risk for
suffering from schizophrenia later as an
adult and this probably has a
stress-related mechanism and the root of
all that is social stress ok social
stress meaning there are too many people
in such a crowded place well social
stress is the combination of social
density on the one hand and social
isolation on the other hand when two of
these two stressors combine the mixture
can become toxic so why is that I mean
I'm am i lonely when I live in a big
city
not necessarily most of us actually most
people rather benefit from living in
large cities they benefit from what is
called the urban advantage but they're
but they're at risk population
like older people like migrants for
example who rather who don't have the
the coping instruments to deal with
isolation or with deal with with density
who can't escape the density of cities
and then this becomes health relevant so
say if you take a look at the brain of
some people living in a big city and at
the brain and people living in rural
areas do you actually see difference in
the brain structure or how it works well
there was a very nice study here from
Germany from Mannheim which showed that
the activity in some regions of the
brain where emotions are processed is
different in city dwellers than in
people from rural areas they show city
dwellers show a large activity stronger
activity in the amygdala which is a very
important brain region which controls
our emotions and what if I would take
some inhabitant of a city and say go get
a farm back buy some piece of land and
get out into a rural area with the brain
change after the the changing in
location well it's probably the first 15
years of our lives that count the the
every single year that you spent growing
growing growing up in a inner city
during those first 15 years increases
your risk for schizophrenia later on so
this is the probably the vulnerable
period you said that people living in
cities shouldn't sit at home behind the
closed door they should go out and live
the city what you mean by that well it's
it's always helpful to to spend as much
time in front of your door than behind
your own doorstep to increase the your
social connections with your peers with
your neighbors and that protects from
social isolation and social isolation is
a big major health risk so if you just
would well social isolation is one of
the important social stressors which is
as harmful for our
as like a smoking or even obesity and as
is social density and spending much time
in front of your doors than behind it
protects but we're not thing of myself
going through building it I can see the
tube going there planes
rushing over my head and it's also
stressful a lot of lots of people and
I'm feeling stressed after this so so
but you say I have to go and and and to
feel it why does this help well it's
it's because it helps to not avoid what
stresses you out but to face it and to
to expose yourself and to concentrate on
different details for example a a walk
through your city or through your
neighborhood even where you focus on the
details on the trees on the on the
streets on the benches that you see it's
helpful to to make the environment more
familiar to you like the awareness you
have when you go through a forest you go
just go through the city and have some
meditation there like this so you found
it a group an interdisciplinary group
with architects neuroscientists all
working together to find some solution
to the problem of the stressful city and
what things are you looking at yeah so
at the beginning of the of this year
we've found it as the forum new urbanism
which is a group of newer of architects
of city planners and neuroscientists
together with the Alfred hair house in
society and we try to put our
methodologies together to to learn from
each other and to in order to better
understand how a perfect city which is
good for our health should be shaped and
as a result you're designing something
like a stress map for the city what's
that about well stress map is something
we're targeting at - because we think
it's it in order to understand in order
to understand what is stressful about
the city you in what city stress is
exactly composed from it can be helpful
to to map it to ask for example a lot of
people inhabitants of the city to to
rate their well-being or their anxiety
or their stress level on an app and as a
result we have something like an
emotional map which helps us to
understand what is where are the
stressful points and sources of city
living dr. Ali thanks so much for being
with us good shape today things